if you'd like to support more content on
the channel and get some epic anime
merch check out our online store anime
out Broadcom we have original designs
that were done exclusively for us by pro
manga artist Cuusoo mati including this
dream big work hard
hasta shirt for your fan of the channel
feel free to use the discount code
uproar 25 at checkout for an instant 25%
off
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today we will be
talking about the recent massive reveals
in the black clovers story including the
tragic truth behind the elf massacre the
real names and hidden pasts of the first
wizard King and Nero and much more the
black clover manga is just so
interesting right now and I've been
feeling inspired to make more black
clover content here on the channel if
you'd like to see more black clover
videos please leave a like to let me
know and of course if you're new to
anime or subscribing and hitting diagnol
fake Asian Belle really helps me out
because I'm gonna be dealing with the
latest developments in the story this
video will contain manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned as chapter 204 starts and
the first wizard king and Nero are
flying off to fight the devil
we finally get a flashback to 500 years
ago and we learned the truth about the
past
we learned that Nero's real name is
Sacre and that her magic is to open and
close things so she possesses sealing
magic now there is nothing gonna be some
debate about how to pronounce Nero's
true name especially since the spelling
of her true name is different in the
unofficial and the official translations
I'm gonna be pronouncing its crap
because in the official translation on
the VIS website it is spelled s-e-c r e
with an acute accent also known as
accent aigu in french i believe that her
name is most likely a reference to the
french language especially after we
learned what the first wizard king's
true name is and even though it is
written differently Nero's name is most
likely a reference to the French word
secret which is pronounced Sucre
and for that reason I believe that sakra
is the proper pronunciation of Nero's
real name
at any rate even though she was
unknowable Sacre's unique type of magic
wasn't highly valued by others and she
was tasked with being the servant of the
first wizard king who was at the time a
prince the prince was known for being
eccentric and possessing incredible
magical talents that stood out even
the Royals the prince was very
interested in researching ancient magic
in creating magic items and he was
extremely curious and open-minded about
all the different types of magic
including sucres sealing magic in fact
the prince is especially impressed with
Sakura's ability to seal magic into
objects and we know that will come in
handy later at this point we see a
glimpse of some of the magical tools
that the prince is working on and this
includes the black dress that Sacre AKA
nero is wearing when we first see her
return to her normal human form this
makes me think that the dress is very
likely related to the fact that Sucre
was able to assume the form of an aunty
bird and stay alive for over 500 years
it is also worth noting that in the
flashback of Sucre from 500 years ago
she does not appear to have the black
horns that she has after she transforms
back into her true form from the aunty
bird form this seems to indicate that
she started out as a normal human noble
but that something changed along the way
I'm not sure whether the horns are just
related to the black dress itself which
we know is a magic tool or whether she
had to use some type of forbidden magic
or demonic magic in order to seal the
first wizard King inside the statue and
to seal herself inside the Nero form and
this somehow resulted in her taking some
form of demonic magic into herself and
that is why she now has horns if this
were the case it would explain how she
was able to locate Austin the 5-leaf
grimoire because we know that the demons
slash devils can sense each other and
there is of course a demon inside the
5-leaf grimoire but that is just
speculation at this point while she was
working with the Prince 500 years ago
sakra noticed that the prince and his
sister Tatia were sneaking out to meet
the elves and she notices that just like
the prince licked also has a 4-leaf
grimoire Sakura believes that in licked
the princess finally found a friend who
can be his equal and of course the two
of them share a joint commitment to
bringing peace and harmony between the
different races including the humans and
the elves the Prince Tatyana Licht
wanted to unite the humans and elves and
they wanted to combine the unique
abilities talents and magical knowledge
that the two races possessed in order to
make life better for everyone
however just
for the wedding ceremony between lift
and petia was to take place the prince
is unexpectedly summoned by his father
the king because the location of the
wedding ceremony was kept a secret and
the King had no way of knowing about it
the prince doesn't think much of it and
he goes off to meet his father but
instead of his father the prince is
confronted by one of the Kings ministers
and it turns out that this Minister was
possessed by the devil
the same devil who is now the main
villain in the story 500 years later the
devil is capable of possessing the
bodies of others and he was able to use
the minister to manipulate the humans he
uses his powerful magic to restrain the
prince and the devil reveals his master
plan he intends to make the elves think
that they were betrayed by the Prince
because only he knows the secret
location of the wedding ceremony we
later learned that the devil intended to
take possession of Lix body and use it
as a powerful vessel for himself but in
order to take possession of Lix body he
first needed to make Licht succumb to
total despair in the same way that Patri
does five centuries later sakra manages
to release the prince from the devil's
binding magic by using her sealing magic
which just proves how useful and strong
her magic actually is we now know how
opie the devil is and yet Sacre is able
to undo his binding magic even though
she was always insecure about the
usefulness of her magic it seems that
she is actually extremely gifted and
powerful unfortunately by the time that
Sucre and the Prince arrive at the
wedding ceremony it is already too late
the devil appears to have used the
princes own magic tools to carry out the
massacre
and when Sucre and the Prince arrive
everyone except lift is already dead and
lift is in a state of total despair as
he still holds
Tatia in his arms the devil is
attempting to take control of lifts body
by feeding on his despair and outrage
but when lift sees the prince in Sacre
he confirms what he suspected all along
the prince was not the one who betrayed
the elves and the massacre was a setup
this realization allows liqu to
partially regain control of his body but
he is still unable to withstand all of
the negative mana that the devil is in
using him with in a last-ditch effort to
stop the devil from taking control of
his powerful body Licht uses the magic
stones in order to turn himself into the
giant demon God creature that had
attacked the clover kingdom according to
legend and that was ultimately defeated
by the first wizard king at this point
it is revealed that the first wizard
Kings true name is Lumiere and lifts
final words are for Lumiere to kill him
in his giant demon form so that the
devil cannot take possession of his body
I am not completely sure why exactly
lift had to use forbidden magic in order
to turn himself into a giant demon but I
assumed that doing this somehow made it
harder for the devil to take possession
of his body and this is what the devil
was talking about several chapters
earlier when he said that the first
wizard King and Licht managed to work
together to stop the devil from
successfully incarnated into this world
so it is now finally confirmed that the
giant demon that the first wizard King
defeated was actually lifts
transformation and it is confirmed that
both the humans and the elves were
manipulated and tricked by the devil
since no one except for Lumiere and
Tatia would have known about the
location of the wedding ceremony and
this includes the king and his minister
it is clear that the devil had some
other way of learning the secret
location of the wedding this might mean
that the devil was already secretly
working with an elf like Ron and before
he even possessed his body or with
someone else that we still don't know
about another important thing to note is
that Lumiere the first wizard Kings name
means light in French and Licht means
light in German and Dutch this
emphasizes the close connection between
the two of them and how both of these
characters symbolize light whereas the
devil and the demons symbolized darkness
as I said the meaning of Nero's true
name sacre sounds a lot like the word
secret in French although it is written
differently the pronunciation is similar
and with the princes name being Lumiere
a clear reference to the French language
it is fair to assume that Sucre is a
reference to the word secret the only
question is whether the secret in
question is the fact that the bird Nero
wasn't actually who we thought or if
there is yet another secret that's a
crane
is keeping from us and that will come to
light sometime in the future in these
most recent chapters of the black clover
manga we have learned so much about the
world of black clover and we gained a
much better understanding of the tragic
events surrounding the elf massacre 500
years ago but there are still a lot of
unsolved questions as well how exactly
did the devil find out about the exact
location of the wedding ceremony even
though it was a closely guarded secret
were there other elves who were working
with the devil or was Ronan working with
the devil even before the devil
possessed his body and if so then why
would any elf do this why would any elf
team up with the devil in order to
Massacre their own people unless the
devil was taking turns possessing
sometimes humans sometimes elves but
that still wouldn't explain how he was
able to find the elves since they all
lived in secret also how exactly did
Sacre and Lumiere managed to seal
themselves away for 500 years just to
reappear again once the devil made his
move and what is their plan right now
how do they plan to defeat someone so
overpowered especially now that he has
taken on a physical form do Sakura and
Lumiere have some hidden tricks up their
sleeve and will the artificial licked
fully awaken at some point and play a
role in defeating the devil also what
can we expect from you know and hasta
how will they fit into Lumiere and
secrets planned let me know what you
guys think about all these questions
down in the comments I always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed the
black clover content on this channel and
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell a huge
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for supporting our work when I
especially thank our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
keelon and chubs is the man and another
huge thank you to our the one to your
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ace Matty Mac
James L Olin Adam Ingrid ah and OMA
and at the very pinnacle of
interdimensional greatness the tier
reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to baby Rey the first-ever
disciple of Lord to ego himself if you
guys feel that our content provides
value for you and you want to support
more be sure to check out our patreon
link in the description even donating a
single dollar will give you access to
our anime up for patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]